you mean more to me than anything in
this whole world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
did you ever wonder about Tinkerbell's
backstory where did the ferry come from
how did she get that outfit will dish
out all the details including her secret
sister keep watching to the end to
discover the little-known story of how
tink and Peter Pan first met the 1953
Disney movie Peter Pan doesn't give us
any information about where Tinkerbell
came from or how she met the boy who
wouldn't grow up but more than 50 years
later tink got her own series of films
and we learned a whole lot more about
her welcome to Pixie Hollow
however the question of her friendship
with Peter remained unanswered for many
fans what in the world was that Tinker
Bell but we've discovered all the secret
details about how the two first laid
eyes on each other it was pretty
dramatic stay tuned for that reveal but
first of all let's learn about Tinker
Bell's origins the narrator of the 2008
movie Tinker Bell explains how fairies
come into being she says the first time
that a baby laughs a fairy's life we're
showing how the laugh travels on white
dandelion fluff all the way to Pixie
Hollow in Neverland it's just past the
second star to the right in case you
didn't know
so that's fairies in general but what
about Tinker Bell specifically we think
that tink was born of a baby's laughs in
London England another fairy was also
born on that babies laughs keep watching
to learn more about that tinks dandelion
fluff lands in Pixie Hollow and Terence
the dust-keeper pours pixie dust over
her
that's when she transforms into the
fairy we know and love hello
well not quite her hair is loose around
her shoulders and she's wearing a white
dandelion fluff dress she gets her
signature style a little later the Queen
of Pixie Hollow Queen Clarion welcomes
tink with the words born
after clothes cheer happiness has
brought you here after Queen Clarion
teaches the new arrival how to fly
tinkas had to find her talent what are
these things they will help you find
your talent will she be a garden talents
fairy water talents fairy wind talents
very light talents fairy or animal
talents fairy she passes by symbols of
each talent and they wither away from
her tink passes right by the hammer but
it glows and follows her as she touches
it it sparkles brightly to show that she
is a tinker fairy
so her talent is to make and mend things
tink puts her newfound talent to use
straightaway when she moves into her new
home there is a closet full of leaf
outfits waiting for her but she's so
small that they all swamp her so the
resourceful fairy sets about cutting
them to size creating her iconic green
leaf mini dress she also scoops up her
hair to keep it out of her eyes and
creates her signature bun and bangs we
mentioned earlier that tink has a secret
sister if this is news to you then
you're probably imagining another fairy
in a green leaf dress with a cute updo
but you'd be wrong in the 2012 movie
Tinkerbell secret of the wings we
discover a big secret about Tinker
Bell's past she has a sister but her sis
look so little different with an ice
white pixie crop for her hairdo and a
light blue pantsuit for her outfit tink
find out about her long-lost sister when
she visits the winter woods tink so warm
season fairy so she isn't allowed to go
into the cold part of Pixie Hollow
because it would destroy her delicate
wings however when she stands on the
border her wings sparkle in the most
magical way determined to learn the
truth behind the sparkle they actually
ripped up tink Stow's away to the winter
woods to speak with dewy the keeper of
fairy knowledge that's when she
discovers another fairy periwinkle who
has the exact same wings in Pixie Hollow
wings are like fingerprints everyone's
are different or nearly everyone's that
is
when those matching wings are closed
they sparkle periwinkle is a frost
talent fairy who has been living in the
winter woods all this time without tink
realizing dewy shows them the moment
that they came into being on the same
laughs and how their dandelion fluff got
separated on the journey to Pixie Hollow
neither one of them knew that the other
existed it's a totally magical moment
when the girls are reunited the rest of
the movie goes on to explore how their
bond threatens the whole of Pixie Hollow
and how their bond then saves all of
faerie kind if that sounds dramatic just
wait until you hear about Tinker Bell
and Peter Pan's introduction to each
other
we discover how tank and Peter first met
in the first-ever Disney Fairies chapter
book published in 2006 the book is
called the trouble with tink in a story
Tinkerbell loses her hammer which means
she starts to lose her talent as a
tinker fairy so she decides to visit
Peter to find it we discover that she's
distance herself from him after he
brought Wendy back to Neverland when the
two reunites they reminisce about the
moment they first laid eyes on each
other Peter was trying to steal a
shark's tooth he was on a small boat
trying to knock the shark out cold with
his oar however the shark was bigger
than he expected and it bit Peters raft
in half he didn't know how to fly yet so
Tinker Bell came to his rescue she
taught him how to fly with a sprinkling
of fairy dust and saved Peter from the
shark talk about an action-packed
introduction so that's a wrap on the
truth about Tinker Bell's backstory and
how she met Peter Pan do you wish to
computers stayed together forever let us
know in the comments and remember we all
need a little faith trust and pixie dust
in our lives make sure to subscribe to
the things and don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up thanks for
watching catch you next time
[Music]